actually some good work was done here in
the United States in the last 15-20
years around water conservation new
buildings had to have low flush toilets
and so on in some states a lot of states
are breaking that but there you know
there are very basic things that we can
do from making sure again back here to
the US making sure the infrastructure is
repaired so we're not losing water and
we're not pumping out dirty water from
these old pipes that would make a huge
difference it would mean once people
really trust their tap water they could
stop drinking bottled water they should
stop it anyway but and they would really
you know the more they trust their tap
water the less they're likely to do that
which means you stop pumping the
aquifers so fast more sustainable
agriculture and there's a lot of people
turning to a local organic food
production you know we're saying things
like you know when you buy flowers on
Valentine's Day
buy local you know if they've come from
far away they've probably come from
situations where some water is being
destroyed in some community I mean we
just put out a report about the flower
industry around Lake Naivasha in Kenya
in the Rift Valley where Out of Africa
was filmed that gorgeous film Out of
Africa and it's being destroyed by the
European Rose industry
rose as in roses flowers you know that
these big businesses have surrounded the
lake they said growing roses is water
intense and they don't want to use the
water in Europe so they were using the
water here right and they're destroying
the lake it'll be and I quote a putrid
pub puddle in five to ten years this
gorgeous lake where Robert Redford see I
was there I could see Robert Redford
landing his plane and Meryl Streep
saying hello I mean it was just
beautiful it's going to be dead dead a
dead lake and so and it's got the last
wild hippopotamus herd in in East Africa
I mean it's really a tragedy and this is
just a story that's repeating itself all
over the world so yes there are many
reclamation projects and and and but but
they do I really think mean that we're
going to have to think differently about
all our economic systems we're going to
have to have
economic policies that promote and
support local production and local more
organic sensible food production the
Green Revolution in the third world was
a disaster because it used chemicals and
those chemicals needed way more water so
that you could disperse the chemicals
and so they just dried up entire regions
and so we're going to have to come back
to things people knew a long time ago a
lot of the indigenous knowledge a lot of
the knowledge that our farmers had
before we started industrial farming and
our cities were going to have to build
different cities we're going to have to
build cities that have lots of parks I
love your park here I would jogged in in
Central Park this morning it but you
know green things on our roofs you know
Roof Gardens and and and leaving the
rivers and the stream so that we build
around we don't build over this
dominance of humans you know that we can
somehow master nature gotta get rid of
that gotta come to a place where we
we're more respectful of the earth that
gave us lights and and the water that
sustains that like